we are taking phone calls at 6 1 7 8 30
40 750 we'll take our next caller who's
uh who's on the line well my name's day
i'm calling from dallas texas i really
appreciate you taking my call my
pleasure was all right I'm self-employed
self-employed saw a lot healthcare.gov
for my health insurance right since
you're all so self-employed I was
wondering if you also rely on health
care healthcare.gov for your insurance
and how that's working for you she do I
don't rely on healthcare.gov because
here in Massachusetts we've had this
thing called Romneycare longer than the
Affordable Care Act which is in many
ways it goes above and beyond the
minimum requirements of the Affordable
Care Act so we have something in
Massachusetts called the health
connector which is basically a way that
you can see at a glance what plans are
available there's also some groups that
let you do uh you know small business
group plans etc so i don't use
healthcare.gov because we've got
something else here in massachusetts and
and you know that's something i've been
talking about in the discussion about
whether Trump is going to keep or get
rid of the Affordable Care Act and we
know he said some of the provisions are
very good it's possible he'll get rid of
it and replace it with something very
similar whatever else ends up happening
there are some states I don't know what
the list is Massachusetts is one that
won't by and large be too affected by
that because they have their own systems
and I know Texas is not one of those
states as you're telling us yeah that's
true what a curiosity what's happened to
your premiums since in the last few
years you prefer people in massachusetts
ave skyrocketed or uh you know I I don't
have broader state data um the plans i'm
aware of have seen slight increases and
you know premium sort of always increase
and there have been slight increases and
i think it really matters whether it you
know there's heavily subsidized plans
through something called MassHealth
where people actually don't pay anything
in some cases and then there's different
gradations of subsidy and then you've
got just sort of like your regular
market plans where you don't go through
what's called the
connector you just call up Harvard
Pilgrim or Tufts or whatever health
insurance company you want and and those
may not be company names that that
resonate with people in other parts of
the country uh and you can just sort of
by directly so it you know premiums have
increased but how it compares to what we
were seeing pre Affordable Care Act I'm
not exactly sure about that but all very
good questions and we're going to talk
about the impact of this on small
business owners and others once we
finally see what Trump care is going to
look like Dave well you know for me
personally just real quickly I seen my
my insurance go literally as of this
year I want to keep my doctor i'll be
paying three times more than i was
paying just a few years ago so the
monthly premiums would be you're saying
the monthly premium would be three times
as much and that doesn't count co-pays
or anything else it would be if i want
to keep my dog that's right i do if i
want to keep my doctor that i have i've
had for 25 years yeah i would be paying
1500 dollars a month to keep her as my
doctor i can get a another plan it's the
cheapest plan is offered in dallas and
it's almost a thousand dollars a month
and i was looking at the doctors the
only have real doctors it's all
physicians assistants they don't have
any just general practitioners no not
dr. won't even take the insurance you
know but but here's the thing that has
to be really nervous about it because I
hear President Obama when he was going
around bragging about how seventy
percent of the people on through the
Affordable Health Care now get their
insurance for less than 100 hours a
month and done that a vast majority get
it for less than 75 hours and the reason
they were able to get it for that amount
is the reason why i'm paying so much
money every month I'm literally
subsidizing their health care and their
pricing me out and so I know the
insurance broker that I used to use
before the healthcare.gov site made it
so easy for me to just pick it out
myself he's now reaching out to people
like me self-employed people and he's
telling us about these cost sharing
plans that are offered through
ministries don't know if you're familiar
with them or not I have not heard of
health insurance through this is their
offer to religious organizations I'm not
really a religious person I'm a
spiritual person but not a religious
person I can't stand the thought of
getting my health care relying on a
religious organization
but my health care this is scares the
hell out of ya that is very very clear
that they don't have to pay you and they
make it clear that they're not actually
on the hook for your payments but
they're supposed to pay for it and the
way it is everybody chips and money and
then they share the expenses and have a
long story I could be getting my
insurance through them for three hundred
ninety nine dollars a month with the one
thousand dollar out of pocket for the
year which sounds phenomenal to me yeah
but I don't want to do it because I
don't want to be reliant on a on a
religious organization yeah but I
completely agree with you on that Dave I
do i do have to move on it's a very
important issue which we're going to be
covering and you know fundamentally the
system is just not a good system that
none of this should be for profit and I
really do appreciate the call and uh
hope to talk to you again